Whether you are waiting for the exam, or you will start an important presentation, or you are in
Starting a race, we all experienced nervousness / anxiety. But why are we nervous? Is surveillance
Professional athletes help us understand how to deal effectively with it?
In difficult situations, the brain sends a signal from the pituitary gland
The way to the kidneys where the adrenal gland is located. This is where adrenaline is released.
It has been felt before - the speed of the heartbeat, the dilated pupil and increased circulation
In your muscles. This is all part of the response to the "war or flight" that has grown in
Our evolutionary history to help us survive. But this response is not all or nothing - there
Degrees of reaction, according to the perceived threat or significance of the result
View. So something like an interview, which is challenging, motivates
The biological reaction itself is a threat to your life - but to a lesser degree.
Feel those "moving butterflies" in your stomach? This is because adrenaline helps to reorient
Blood and energy to the most important parts of your body during stress, such as the heart
Muscle, and away from the digestive system causing the closure of the blood vessels
Around your stomach and cause you to feel these pokes.
So, how do professional athletes deal with stress and nerves?
The concept of "mental images" is a widely used method in famous sports
Defined cognitive, "athletes simply imagine themselves practicing technique or skill
Before competition or training. Although this seems crazy, it actually stimulates
Brain related neurons in the brain, showing that they have a role in promoting specific skill.
"Specific motivational images" on the other hand encourage athletes to remember a feeling
Winning an event or overcoming a competitor as a motivational tool. Finally, "Mastery
General motivation "skill that is commonly used by athletes to feel more confident. Again, simply by imagining
Concentrate themselves as strong and with positive feelings and thoughts before the competition, become athletes
Able to improve performance and overcome nerves. Trust, in particular, is a constant factor of
The factors that distinguish successful athletes from others, and receive great attention from
Professional Trainers.
So, the next time you feel those nerves roll inside you, try to prepare as an Olympic champion Lucent! What
Are you waiting? Stand on your mark, get ready, go!
Do not forget: we have a new video every day during the Olympics.
I can not wait? Our CBC partners already have five videos so far for you to follow.
Just go to cbc.ca/olympics/ScienceSays to see it before anyone else. Link in description.
But we also want to know your questions for this special series. Use the ScienceSays Mark and let us know your Olympic questions.
Subscribe to more great videos!